اصيب فلسطينيين برصاص قوات الاحتلال بعد
اقتحام قوه خاصه اسرائيليه حاره العموري
في مخيم بلاطه الشرقيه نابلس بالضفه
الغربيه وقال شود عيان ان القوه الخاصه
حاصرت منزلا بالمخيم وطلبت احد الشبان
بتسليم نفسه وسط اشتباكات مسلحه واضاف
الشهود ونقوات الاحتلال اطلقت قذيفه
صاروخيه على المنزل خلال العمليه العسكريه
معنا من رام الله مراسل الجزيره سميره
بوشماله سميره اهلا بك ما الذي قال اليه
الوضع في مخيم بلاطه
نعم من قبل نحو ساعه من الان بدات عمليه
عسكريه جديده استهدفت فيها اطراف مخيم
بلاطه شرقي مدينه نابلس حيث تسللت الى
داخل المخيم
قوه عسكريه خاصه وحاصرت احد المنازل وايضا
نشرت القناصه على محيي في محيط البنايات
او المحيط المنزل المستهدف وايضا دفعت
قوات الاحتلال بتعزيزات الاضافيه مصحوبه
بجرافه عسكريه الى من عده محاور الى داخل
المخيم وطالبت ايضا الاحد الشبان
المقاومين بتسليم نفسه وهو المقاوم حسب ما
اعلن عنه في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي عصام
الصلاج والذي يعتبر بقيادات كتيبه بلاطه
في المقاومين الفلسطينيين في داخل المخيم
ولكنه يرفض تسليم نفسه قبل قليل
كان هناك مقابله لاحد لوالد هذا الشاب
الذي تحدث بان ضباط المخابرات الاسرائيليه
قد اتصلوا عليه عده مرات وطالبوها بالحضور
الى المنزل وذلك لاقناع ابنه بتسليم نفسه
ولكنه رفض ذلك وجيش الاحتلال قد هدد بضرب
المنزل الذي ياوي عدد من الفلسطينيين من
عائله الصلاج وبيدهم هذا المطلوب واطلق
القذائف الصاروخيه على هذا المنزل حيث سمع
قبل قليل اصوات انفجارات في داخل في محيطه
هذا المنزل وفي داخل المنزل مما وهذا كما
ذكره هو شهود الاعيان من داخل مخيم بلاطه
خلال هذه العمليه خرجت مجموعات مقاومه
تتصدى لهذه القوه العسكريه
وقامت بيع الاشتباك المسلحه العنيف مع
قوات الاحتلال الايطاليه التي انتشرت في
ارجاء من المخيم بلاطه وايضا هذه الكتائب
من كتائب مجموعات بلاطه وكتيبه
نابلس وايضا عريض مجموعات عرين الاسود
وغيرها من الفصائل الفلسطينيه المسلحه
التي تصدت لهذه القوه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه خلال هذه العمليه وايضا
المصادر الطبيه الفلسطينيه تحدثت وتحديدا
وزاره الصحه والهلال الاحمر تحدثوا بان
اصابتين على الاقل اصيب اصيبت خلال هذه
العمليه العسكريه بالرصاص جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وصفت احداها بالخطيره حيث
اصيبت بمنطقه في منطقه الصدر وايضا هناك
اصابه لاخر في منطقه القدم والكوع ولكن
الهلال الاحمر قبل قبل لحظات تحدث عن
اصابه ثالثه
لطفل في القدم داخل احد المنازل ولكن قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه منعت الطواقم الطبيه
من الوصول الى هذا المنزل وهناك عمليه
تنسيق مع اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
للوصول الى هذا الطفل ونقله الى مستشفى
هذه العمليه ما زالت مستمره وهي تستهدف
كما ذكرنا احد المطلوبين لدى قوات
الاحتداد الاسرائيليه سمير ابو شماله من
رام الله شكرا جزيلا لك